amazing amazing work over the last year
you for me someone that you remind me of
is Tony Robbins
I think he's taller this someone that
knows how to
inspire people to self-actualization and
I find that to be deeply needed in our
world and that's what you've been doing
and it's brilliant beautiful and I think
this is why you bring people together
like this so so something that you
brought to the attention of so many
people
is the dominance or competence hierarchy
why what let's maybe talk about what
what's the difference dominance or
competence hierarchy I kind of like
competence hierarchy yeah it's better
yeah yeah well I got this colleague his
name is Daniel Higgins and I've been
working with him for like 25 years he
helped me design the self authoring
suite which is a series of programs
writing programs that are online that
help people uh write about their lives
their past and their present there
virtues in their faults and to make a
plan for the future and we've talked a
lot he he was a
he has a master's degree at MIT in
engineering and then he went to Harvard
he was a student of mine there and he
got a PhD in Experimental Psychology
we've been working on these
psychological interventions online ever
since and we talk fairly frequently and
I'd been using the term dominance
hierarchy a lot which it's something
that's used by biologists very regularly
right because most social animals even
animals that aren't social any animals
that have to compete for occupation of a
specific territorial space tend to
organize themselves into fairly
predictable hierarchies and it's it's
it's a biological Universal that's a
good way of thinking about it which is
something really important to know right
because if you don't know that then you
might think that hierarchical
organizations are some secondary
consequence of a socio-political
structure and economic structure or
something like that and it's just that's
just not true it isn't even a little bit
true it's unbelievably not true and well
this is partly why in ruel in 12 rows
for life I wrote about the nervous
system of crustaceans in in rule number
one because the neurobiological systems
that we have evolved or that have
evolved to deal with dominance hierarchy
placement I'll get to the competence
issue in a minute or at least a third of
a billion years old and that's far
longer than theirs that's that's there
weren't trees a third of a billion years
ago so dominance hierarchies
hierarchical organizations among animals
are older than trees it's like there's
no blame in them on capitalism right
this is it's just well seriously the
hierarchies have problems that they're
problematic social structures but you
can't blame them on on
on on cultural you can't blame them on
culture anyways we were talking about
dominance hierarchies and dr. Higgins
said you can't call them dominance
hierarchies I said why not I said he
said well unless you're in an
organization where you can put a dog
leash around someone's neck and lead
them around it's not a dominance
hierarchy and I thought he's kind of
blunt as you might have noticed by that
comment kind of shocked me a because
because it was so blunt there's lots of
that that happens in San Francisco yeah
well the thing is well you know that
that's actually an operable comment
because dominance is just as old as
sexuality perhaps perhaps not quite as
old it's not quite as old as sexuality
but it's old enough so that the two
things get tangled together very very
inevitably so he said
he said two things that I thought were
really interesting and the first was
that human organizations are
sufficiently complex so the dominance is
an insufficient means of establishing
hierarchical priority but that's good
and I thought that's right I knew that
soon as he said that I thought yeah I
shouldn't be using the term dominance
hierarchy because Fran's de Waal who's a
Dutch primatologist what a series of
excellent books on the emergence of
morality and chimpanzees I would highly
recommend them they're very interesting
books one of the things de Waal noted
was that in chimpanzee hierarchies the
brutal males can rise to the top but
they tend to have very short-lived
empires and to meet very very violent
deaths and so his his conclusion was
that in order even for a chimpanzee
hierarchy to be stable across time then
the top chimp had to be quite pro-social
so first of all had to engage in
sufficient reciprocal behavior so that
he had allies among other males right
because otherwise if you're like top
chimp and you're cavemen strong man type
and and you've established your
dominance merely as a matter of
intimidation and strength then if you
have an off day two of your slightly
weaker opponents can tear you to pieces
which is exactly what the chimps do
because they're quite brutal in there
there's no evidence that chimpanzees
have any internal regulation of the
violence that they'll use to shift
dominance hierarchy position and so you
end up castrated for example by your
opponents which is something that the
wall noted in the Arnhem zoo so he found
that the stable chimp troops had males
at the helm who were who had friendships
because chimps actually have social
friendships really that can stretch
across many years decades even and that
they track them very well very
reciprocal in their behavior tended to
treat the females relatively well by
chimp standards and also tended to pay a
fair amount of attention to the infants
which is an unbelievably important
finding right because it indicates at a
level that's below the human let's say
that there's an ethic associated with
leadership that isn't a mere consequence
of raw power and then so that was the
first thing that Higgins pointed out and
the second thing was that he thought and
and I haven't I don't know how true this
is yet he thought that some of what the
ethologist hsihu had used the term
dominance hierarchy to apply to animals
might have been doing was using an
intrinsically Marxist framework to
interpret animal behavior and to
overestimate the degree to which
dominance was actually the core
foundation of hierarchical organizations
even among animals and the first ones
the first objection he had that's
definitely the case this is true the
second one is interest competence yeah
yeah well did the idea that that it's
pure power is an unstable basis for for
for stable hierarchy that's
well-documented and I think that has
probably moved into the realm of
empirically verifiable fact the second
one that the initial idea that it was
dominance per se that was at the basis
of hierarchical arrangements was in part
a quasi Marxist interpretation or
projection I think that's disputable
because I think what happens is that as
you go down the the phylogenetic chain
to simpler and simpler animals it looks
more and more like power physical
prowess essentially is the determining
factor it certainly seems to be the case
among lobsters for example crustaceans
they're of interest because they have
seen there there's a lobster again they
have relatively simple nervous systems
relatively they're still very complex
with large neurons that are easily
observable and a neuro chemistry that
differs from humans but is the same is
similar in